it's go again you know I get down
Funkmaster Flex and be clear all the big
dogs
no make my bed face to cook rule the
streets turn my headphones up you need
to get with it act like you want it for
your the knife will fit the cup just cuz
you didn't go up planning this board
double your rainy in Iranian bottle
stabbed people killing people fight drop
the beat out man go ready rocket you
ready to see how we do all the streets
all right
make it beat what this is I'll let you
I'm saying
you don't know about
that's the cuffs but now something's
wrong with you
he's got the illest joint out right now
he's crazy with it turn my headphones up
nigga I'm serious I can't that's right
[Music]
this lyrics are so tight they don't even
have to run and the word on the street
this late night one night in the ghetto
my man got shot put some treble in it
put some travel in it that's my word
alright here we go some water
[Music]
[Applause]